late last year the Argentinean President
Cristina Fernandez walked into an angry
press conference there be riots looting
vandalism across the country the country
is a mess why one of the reasons was the
police had been on strike because at
that time in Argentina police wages were
linked to the official rate of inflation
and so that when the government said the
prices are going up ten percent a year
it also meant the wages go up ten
percent a year but what every policeman
and almost everyone else in the country
knew was that actually when they went to
the local shops prices were going up to
three times as quickly so in real terms
they were able to buy fewer and fewer
goods with their monthly salaries they
were getting poorer so they went on
strike
so what i did when i saw this press
conference so i went online to a project
run out of MIT called the billion prices
project now what the billion prices
project does is it scours the
argentinian internet for price data and
it pulls it down and totals it up and
tries to get a rough proxy for inflation
is so goes the ebay of argentina the
amazon of argentina and it says for
example that a microwave last month
costs one hundred dollars this month
across 120 dollars therefore prices have
gone up twenty percent it does it with
every good in real time and pulls it
into an index so in Cristina Fernandez
said that prices were going up ten
percent here I looked and you saw that
prices were actually going up by thirty
percent here now we have the ability to
hold her accountable and say not only
are you the cause of the riots fanning
out across your country but you are
lying to your people
but it's not just that we able to hold
bad policy makers accountable we can
also help the well-intentioned
policymakers understand the economy
better and therefore make better
decisions before I came to the GSB I was
an economist focused on China and I used
to go and speak to people the US
Treasury Department Bank of England and
the number one question everyone had was
can we trust the Chinese data short
answer is no but it's not really because
the government is manipulating the data
although they do that a little bit it's
mainly because China is such a vast and
fast changing economy that the
government themselves don't have the
tools to collect accurate and timely
data and one of the key data sets is
trade export and import how much is
coming out of the country how much is
going into the country and this is
subject critical gauge because it allows
you to get an insight into the health of
the Chinese economy but more than that
because china is the world's largest
exporter it's a wonderful gauge and
insight into the health of the global
economy but we couldn't trust numbers so
what we did is we went online and we
looked up this data a is data what a is
does is it tracks in real time the
location of ships across the oceans and
so you can pull it up and watch the
ships move across the oceans and so what
we did was counted one two three four we
counted them up and when you total that
and tell you that with what's on those
ships you can get a pretty accurate
picture of what's going on in China's
trade in real time so that at the
beginning of 2013 when the official data
was showing the Chinese trade picture is
improving we knew it'd only be temporary
because the ships were in there but it's
more than just helping out a policy
makers in developing countries is also
developed markets to here in the US for
example late last year the US government
shutdown
we had eight hundred thousand workers
temporarily out of a job they killed all
non-essential services and the
government knew this would have a huge
impact on the US economy then there how
large an impact was hard to quantify
this is critical in the US because in
the US consumer spending accounts for
over seventy percent of GDP but they
didn't have a way of understanding the
impact of the shutdown on the consumer
economy what we're now able to do is to
go on and pull data from places like
Foursquare and Twitter and see where
users have been checking in starbucks
this morning Walgreens Walmart this
afternoon pretty boring right you can
tell you that total it up and
extrapolate out and get a pretty
accurate picture of what the US consumer
is doing in real time and if we've done
this we could have gone to the
government and said because of your
inaction you have cost the US economy 10
billion dollars 11 billion dollars 12
billion dollars five years ago we had no
way of disproving the claims of
President Fernandez we had no way of
double checking the Chinese trade data
we have no way of quantifying the impact
of US government inaction and now we do
I want to repeat this point because I
think it's really important now we have
the ability to hold bad policy makers
accountable and to help good policy
makers make better decisions we have
that ability but we're not using it
Instagram farmville snapchat these are
great product these are clever people
instagram with that people across the
world can share experiences they share
photos farmville people let off steam
play some games snapchat people well but
wouldn't it be amazing if we took our
combined intellect time and resources
and focus them on something bigger if we
had startups or calling out politicians
Fred startups for helped investors with
better more timely accurate soup data
make better investments in education and
health here at Stanford we think a lot
about the outsized impact we can have on
business we think a lot about that we
think less about the outsized impact we
could be having on government now for
the first time in history we have the
ability to play a truly active and
engaged role in running our country
whether in government or not
and so I asked you if you're interested
in helping to run a business what you
also be interested in helping to run a
country thank